so let's let's talk about the kind of
leadership we we deserve and that
uh we need and that we get from the
daily mail
biden's dog major bites another
government employee on white house
grounds while out for a walk
three weeks after biting white house
security guard
i'm i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna pass it off
to you daniel because you're uh
you've you've trained dogs like i take
it it just drives me absolutely crazy i
have two right now
um um i have fostered several dogs but
um
my better half has fostered i would say
in the hundreds he's been doing it for
30 years right i mean fostering dogs you
have them for
you know sometimes three weeks four
weeks five weeks he rehabilitates them
to get them to a good point
so that they will be adopted into a
permanent home um
the fact that a 75 year old
fairly senile man was given a
six-month-old german shepherd
male puppy as a prop right like like the
i i am mad at the bidens for doing this
i'm mad at his handles for doing this
but i am angriest at the foster group
because
the reason why there are so many dogs in
kent in fosters right now
in in in being held in pens
is because they are so stringent on who
fosters a dog
and they are pretty strict right that
you you can't get a dog pretty easily
but this guy somehow got one and he got
a difficult one like german shepherd
they are wonderful dogs but they are by
nature protective dogs they are
guardians and they are
alphas they're dominants right and joe
biden is no alpha no matter how many
aviators he wears
the leather jackets the rhetoric the
come on man i'll jump on
man i'll challenge you to push-ups right
now that is all bluster and a dog is not
as stupid as the american press corps
and that dog is like well guess what you
know be itch
i am the alpha of this family joe
biden's not
disciplining me jill is not this hunter
is off doing something else
i am in charge of this family and that
is why he is biting and that's sad
two people yes okay that you might ask
me putting the dog down
no from my experience of a dog in
multiple states i i'm pretty sure it's
the law in dc
let me tell you something when you are
training a dog
especially a german shepherd if you are
too weak
the dog will not obey you german
shepherds are particularly tough
these are these are soldier dogs man
that's why you know cops use them these
these are
some of the most uh intelligent and
strong dogs joe biden
78 year old man being given these dogs
and you were right as a prop yeah
i was a prop because he wanted to look
cool they made a big deal about the fact
that trump didn't have a dog and what
man doesn't have a dog in the white
house the white house always has dogs
obama got a dog
a portuguese water dog a little dog
right but
leave the portuguese sweater dogs alone
no offense all you portuguese water dogs
out there who are listening to tim cast
but this was a prop this was to make him
look cool and to get that talking point
he has a rescue dog
and i i think it does a lot of damage to
the rescue dog community because it
scares people but he should not have
been given this dog
you can be 75 and foster a german
shepherd puppy
if you have been doing this your whole
life if you can't even
if you know what you are doing if it's
your full-time job and if you are
retired yeah and i'm lucky that i work
from home i live on this farm
but you know what am i my older blue
healer which is a great dog but also is
a guardian dog it's a cattle dog it is
it is an alpha dog he's a year and a
half which is in dog years you know
17 18 and he sometimes i will have to
hold him down and yell it because he's
like i'm in charge you know what i'm
gonna do this and and he will push
and you have to push back if you want to
and now that's why my dog which is a
interesting breed an aggressive not
aggressive a happy excitable breed
but it is as docile it could be that
people come over and they're like oh my
gosh your dog is so sweet
that's not a friggin accident my dog is
sweet because it takes
constant work and this poor major can i
have can i have major biden by the way
i will take major off your hands because
this dog is now probably going to get
put down
as a vicious dog and it's not he's got a
stupid handler what if we're going to
send
in the dog whisperer who's that guy
caesar caesar milan why so biden is on
another reality show
all right you know let's do it dude
humans humans uh are being given a
really bad name lately
because i was talking about this in one
of my earlier segments there's this
really really awful video
where a 65 year old asian woman is
walking to church and some guy just
brutally
beats her just a stomping on her head
can't even watch it it's disgusting
it's horrifying and these two security
guards i just watch and then one of them
walks over and closes the door
even after the attacker leaves some
people are like oh you know he didn't
want to the
security guards couldn't intervene
because they could get in trouble or be
liable and people were like
dude the attacker leaves and the woman
is writhing on the ground and like
raising her hand
and they come and close the door and
walk away they could have gotten their
phones and called somebody into anything
and i'm sitting here like humans are
doing really dumb stuff right now and
animals are starting to look a whole lot
better see this incident with german
shepherd
joe biden was given this dog it was it
was a prop as you said they were like
look at this guy with this dog
and then the dog does dog stuff and now
it's just new another news cycle and i'm
thinking about this story with this
this asian lady and even a rooster
even a rooster will set will run and
fight predators
to protect chickens after it warns the
chickens
it won't make a certain call and the
chickens will run in
which is great but we have people these
days that are are incapable they're weak
and i guess what i'm trying to say is
when you have a culture of people who
just stand there and watch a 65 year old
woman be brutally beaten on the street
and they won't do anything and a rooster
will
something's going good with chicken
society it's not going good with our
society
because we vote for joe biden i i don't
mean we here on the show but 80 million
people vote for this guy
and then he ends up being given this dog
he can't control
i'll tell you this man if he can't
control the german shepherd how
is he going to control putin or kim
jong-un
we are not doing well for ourselves when
we're not electing even someone as
capable as a rooster to protect us
exactly that's that's that's extremely
that is extremely well said
society is going better than america
yeah yeah
chicken city and you know i'm sure they
got this six-month-old puppy and german
shepherd puppies are adorable
as all puppy most puppies are but they
do grow up and it's like people who have
kids and they're like well this will be
fun that's why i hate that mtv show
a teen mom because i think it glorifies
how cool it is to be 15 or 16 and have a
kid
and i think it does a great disservice
because kids do grow up and if they
don't grow up in a good
environment and i'm not i'm just saying
in a good environment we'll leave it at
that
and hunter oh not hunter biden well he
didn't grow up in a great environment
but major biden the dog has now had
three years
not in a good environment with an
undisciplined environment
and look at where he is does that maybe
explain hunter biden uh well you know
there's a there's an awful lot of going
on in hunter biden and
and i will just say this and it's gonna
be a little bit more realistic and i
apologize but i'm just gonna throw it
out there
the laptop stuff is bad the chinese
firms are bad the ukrainian firms is bad
that you are sleeping with your dead
brother's wife
and her sister simultaneously while you
are fathering a child
with a stripper you are a bad person
geez i mean i have lots of
sisters-in-law i couldn't
imagine well for a couple reasons but i
couldn't imagine
my brother dying and being like you know
what she's looking pretty good
and then dating their sister
simultaneously
and having a child with a stripper and
we're supposed to just pretend this is
totally normal
well you know no not allowed to discuss
it you know it's kind of weird about it
it's his child it's his sister-in-law so
it's like
you know he's hooking up with his
sister-in-law and i thought about how
weird it would be that they're like
walking around in a relationship and
they both have the last name biden yeah
and they're not married
and their kids are first cousins but now
they're step brother and sister
so it's like so what do you what does
your dad know is like is it uncle
daddy you know exactly
you know i blame him i blame joe man and
i'm just i'm just imagining
like joe biden standing there with the
dog and the dog bites a guy and then the
dog's like got the guy's arm and he's
like help me joe and joe looks at the
dog and goes come on man
and dog just keeps going and it goes
back to during the transition period
when biden had that cast on and he said
oh he got out of the shower and he
pulled the dog's tail
which hey i've never pulled my dog's
tail that's just not something wait hold
hold on you know
why is the dog in the shower well that's
a little and why are you playing with
your dog naked
also you could say but my point is these
are the questions that when
ivanka tweeted a photo of her
two-year-old making a lego house they
were like we demand to know if he did
this
on his own or did he have help and
you're like what's going on with the
the dog and the naked and the foot and
it's like no no no
and the sun like no not off limits joe
family is off limits
joe biden was in the shower with the dog
in the bathroom
and he opens the shower and tries to
grab the dog's tail you think it was a
towel
and yes oh my god and that's how he
that's how he sprained or broke his face
and not well i don't think maybe the dog
jumped on him
you know maybe the dog is trying to be
the alpha which is what i think probably
happened
or the dog just jumped off the moon fell
over because he's 78.
yeah big german shepherd but there's
something not being told
well i'm going to put it this way um i'm
imagining joe biden
oh i don't want to be imagining this
imagine i'm imagining from
outside the shower and i can't see
within the shower
joe biden is in there he has the door
open and the dog
walks in and is sitting there for some
reason and then hunter
in his i'm not hunter joe in his
senility goes like he reaches and sees
the tail and thinks the tail's a towel
starts pulling on it
yeah and the dog yanks him and he falls
forward and i'm kind of like
i mean it's a little benny hill but
maybe you know maybe
it's a weird story i'm thinking he
pulled the shower curtain open the dog
was like
excited to see him and he maybe even was
like yeah come here and the dog knocked
him down
well exactly it's a dog in the bathroom
and that's the rule like no dog
separation anxiety no dogs in the
bathroom
you know like i i am i am sometimes a
little bit even prudish like dog
like bathroom time my time like my one
dog will try to knock on the door all
the time i'm like nope
outside like bathroom no matter what's
going on in the bathroom no one needs to
be privy to it
animal person i got i gotta ask um
maybe that was the first sign that dog
should have been taken away yeah when we
were like why is dog in the shower
like like or outside the shower or
whatever is going on like what what you
what are you doing joe but now you see
why vladimir putin is challenging him to
a live conversation that has to be
streamed on youtube in real time
and it's like maybe this is why i mean
you know and and i'm not mocking his
his senility because we all have family
members who have gone through and we
witnessed it i have a grandmother i have
a great aunt i've seen it before it's
it's heartbreaking and and it may happen
to me one day but i
i tweeted this actually a couple weeks
ago i like to think
the person i am married to loves me
enough at least that when i am
senile they will protect me from myself
and not parade me around for the world
to see
and what is happening to him right now
in real time we are witnessing
and no one loves him enough to say this
is this is not right and that's
tragic but listen it's everything we
talked about it's weakness
it's people saying i'm not going to get
involved i'm not going to stick my neck
out
it's the security guard saying i'm not
going to help this woman it's
joe biden's own family not telling him
to sit down and shut up joe you're too
old it's time to come home listen man
he's been in he was
he served in government what 47 years i
was saying this when he was running it's
like
joe thank you for your service i'm not a
fan of joe bidenor's policies
but i get it we're going to be we're
going to be respectful and say it's been
a great 47 years
you're 77 years old we got a nice little
rocking chair in the sunroom for you get
your nice little blanket for your lap
and you can read some books
maybe play some candy crush or whatever
it is i don't know you probably need big
glasses because he's pretty old
instead everyone around him is like you
should be the president
and now we're at the point where it's
the biden harris administration
even and you know i wonder i i genuinely
wonder if joe doesn't understand what's
happening around him
i don't know i mean you look at that
summit recently in alaska
um now he wasn't present there but his
administration was and china
just basically laughed at us on our own
territory you look at these these
comments from vladimir putin
um you look at the the increasing
hostility from iran and you say the
world is not
the slightest bit concerned with with
him and so
the the collectivist world the u.n is
pushing
the paris accords the climate change
stuff heck we don't even have the
backbone to stand up and say let's not
have the olympics in china
because they have two million uyghur
slaves who they are beating and raping
on a daily basis
and we're like nah it's cool man make
another disney movie uh to be fair and
with respect the bite administration did
issue sanctions on some chinese
officials from the xinjiang region
so i i can give credit for that good
absolutely we give credit
yeah absolutely um i i hope it's the
right strategy you know i say it that
way because i'm like listen i'm glad
he's doing something
and i hope it's the right move it might
not work it might backfire it may work
perfectly
i'm glad the bind administration is at
least doing something and i wonder if
what was really going on is that china
was was this growing
you know a threat to the u.s to the
world for a lot of reasons
and we ignored it mostly because
didn't sell right you want to run for
office you don't talk about china
you talk about all these other issues i
you know i was we mentioned
uh the other day i was watching man of
the year with robin williams
there's the scene where he's complaining
he's like they're they're talking about
an amendment to the constitution to beg
fl
to ban flag burning while four million
illegal aliens cross our border that was
robin williams saying that mind you so
it's really interesting
but that's the point he's bringing up
when it comes to politics they're going
to come out and they're going to be like
oh look at all these problems we have
and then trump comes out and goes china
and he and he starts that narrative and
now all of a sudden people have started
to realize this
there have been polls showing that even
at a small percentage like a decent i
think it's like 30
of democrats are worried about china
mostly republicans
but not to the point where joe biden's
realizing the sentiment
and the focus on china has become too
much to ignore so now he kind of has no
choice
it's a remnant of the trump era policies
he has to maintain thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you